[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 11 de abril de 2015 se produjo una
histórica reunión entre raúl castro el
presidente de cuba y barack obama
se celebró en panamá y fue el primer
encuentro bilateral entre el presidente
de eeuu y cuba en más de 50 años apenas
cuatro meses antes ambos mandatarios
habían anunciado que iban a retomar las
relaciones entre ambos gobiernos de
james jones y por chivas y dicho y hecho
pronto empezaron a sucederse los cambios
para lograr que las relaciones entre
ambos países
fuesen normales sin embargo amigos una
vez más la llegada de donald trump al
despacho oval lo ha cambiado todo el
nuevo presidente de los eeuu ha ordenado
dar marcha atrás y acabar con muchos de
los cambios que había puesto sobre la
mesa
barack obama respecto a cuba porque lo
hace que espera conseguir que hay
consecuencias va a tener su nueva
política vamos a verlo pero antes vamos
a mirar un poco hacia atrás en el tiempo
el embargo
tras culminarse la llamada revolución
cubana contra la dictadura de batista el
nuevo gobierno de la isla dirigido por
fidel castro comenzó muy pronto a
nacionalizar todo tipo de activos y de
empresas tierras hoteles fábricas todo
fijaos si la revolución cubana culminó
el 1 de enero de 1959 en mayo el
gobierno de la isla ya había comenzado
la expropiación masiva de propiedades
algo que por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar no sentó nada bien en estados
unidos donde las reclamaciones se
contaban por miles y es que por aquel
entonces las relaciones entre ambos
países eran muy estrechas y por si fuese
poco la unión soviética andaba ya
haciendo buenas migas con fidel castro
pues bien en washington respondieron a
las expropiaciones aprobando un primer
embargo comercial contra la isla un
embargo que poco a poco a medida que las
relaciones se deterioraban iba
haciéndose más fuertes de hecho tras la
crisis de los misiles de 1962 kennedy
restringe incluso los viajes de los
estadounidenses a la isla desde entonces
amigos y salvo un corto periodo de
deshielo
las administraciones de fort y cárter
los diferentes gobiernos de eeuu ha
mantenido el embargo y su empeño en
aislar económicamente a cuba- ronald
reagan calificó a la isla como
patrocinador del terrorismo bill clinton
endureció aún más las restricciones y
bajo su mandato el embargo se convirtió
en ley
desde entonces viajar a cuba invertir
allí o tener negocios con el gobierno
cubano ha sido muy restringido para los
estadounidenses pues bien así es esta ha
sido la pauta habitual hasta que llegó
barack obama durante las elecciones de
2008 y coincidiendo además con que en
febrero de ese mismo año
fidel castro le había cedido el poder a
su hermano raúl
obama dijo que había llegado la hora de
emplear un enfoque diferente con cuba y
el momento de recuperar las relaciones
diplomáticas entre ambos países
dicho y hecho obama no se hizo esperar y
al poco de llegar a la casa blanca en el
plazo de apenas unas semanas como primer
gesto de una nueva política alivio
algunas de las restricciones que por
aquel entonces pesaban sobre cuba
por ejemplo permitió que los cubanos en
eeuu pudieran enviar remesas ilimitadas
a la isla y también empezó a abrir la
mano permitiendo que los ciudadanos de
eeuu pudieran viajar a cuba ojo primer
paso al que se sucedieron otros muchos
durante la etapa de obama poco a poco se
fueron moderando muchas de las
restricciones que pesaban sobre cuba en
2014 ambos países anunciaron el
restablecimiento de los lazos
diplomáticos los gestos continuaban por
el cerco yo estemos discutiendo de algo
que no nos pongamos de acuerdo y
disfruto de un breve tiempo o vamos
poner nuevo el pueblo y así llegaron los
dos grandes momentos en 2015 las
embajadas se reabrieron y finalmente en
marzo de 2016 el 'air force one'
aterrizaba por primera vez en la
historia en la habana
qué cubano recibía la visita de un
presidente estadounidense en ejercicio
desde 1928
[Música]
el futuro de cuba tiene que estar en las
manos del pueblo cubano no hay que temer
una amenaza de eeuu no debemos temer al
cambio debemos acoger lo es hora ya de
olvidarnos del pasado miremos al futuro
juntos un futuro de esperanza la nueva
política de obama hacia cuba avanzó con
paso decidido y aunque las leyes del
embargo continuaban en vigor su
administración se las ingenió para
buscar recovecos legales que de facto
permitieran que las relaciones entre
ambos países pues ser normales cuando
obama dejó la casa blanca los
estadounidenses podían viajar a cuba
libremente los inmigrantes podían enviar
remesas de dinero ilimitadas las
empresas estadounidenses podían invertir
en cuba e incluso los aviones de las
compañías estadounidenses aterrizaban
frecuentemente en el aeropuerto
internacional josé martí el aeropuerto
de la habana
vamos que la cosa marchaba pero en estas
donald trump se convirtió en el nuevo
presidente de eeuu y todo cambió
para siempre
presente
trump y cuba el pasado 16 de junio de
2017 trump decidió dar marcha atrás a
toda la política de apertura hacia cuba
lo hizo en el barrio de miami conocido
como little havana con efecto inmediato
canceló la política unilateral de la
administración anterior hacia cuba''
nada más terminar el discurso amigos
trans firmó una directiva para aplicar
lo que él mismo ha denominado su nueva
política aunque la verdad después de más
de 50 años de embargo de nueva política
no tiene nada
[Música]
la marcha atrás de trump no será
completa se mantendrán muchas de las
medidas tomadas por obama como la
apertura de las embajadas o los vuelos
comerciales entre ambos países sin
embargo a partir de ahora se restringen
los viajes de los estadounidenses a cuba
que ya no lo podrán hacer a título
individual y se prohíbe cualquier
relación con gas a un holding
empresarial dirigido por el ejército que
controla más del 50 por ciento de la
economía cubana
ojo no os penséis que donald ha
defendido siempre la mano dura contra
cuba' para nada en el año 98 trató de
construir un hotel en la isla saltándose
el embargo a principios de 2016 decía
apoyar la apertura de obama y luego pues
bueno lo que toque ahora al parecer es
mano dura claro que esto es un error
porque veámoslo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el error de donald trump digámoslo claro
el embargo ha sido un rotundo fracaso el
embargo estadounidense que bloqueó todo
el comercio e inversión con cuba'
durante los últimos 55 años no ha
funcionado no logró aislar al gobierno
cubano no logró recuperar ninguna
propiedad nacionalizada y logró dar una
excusa al gobierno de castro por sus
abusos y la mala administración
económica el embargo continúa
empobreciendo a un pueblo que se siente
naturalmente atraído por los eeuu
durante más de 50 años sin embargo ha
sido totalmente inútil no ha conseguido
ningún objetivo y encima ha sido la
mejor excusa del gobierno cubano para
justificar sus pésimos resultados pero
esperad un momento porque aquí no
termina todo ni de lejos dar marcha
atrás a la política de obama es un error
por muchos motivos por un lado la
normalización de las relaciones con cuba
ha mejorado la seguridad de los propios
eeuu tal como lo escucháis obama firmó
numerosos convenios de colaboración y
por ejemplo desde 2015 las autoridades
cubanas han entregado mucho
información sobre narcotráfico o trata
de personas
por otro lado rusia y china- han vuelto
a poner sus ojos en la isla de hecho
moscú ha llegado a decir que se está
planteando negociar con la habana la
reapertura de bases militares en cuba lo
que supondría una verdadera bofetada a
la estrategia de seguridad nacional de
eeuu
es decir tensar las relaciones y
endurecer el embargo no supone más que
obligar al gobierno de cuba a echarse
otra vez en brazos de moscú o pekín
menudo negocio y aún hay más amigos la
nueva política de trampa no sólo puede
dañar los intereses de muchas empresas
de eeuu sino que también pone en riesgo
los cambios que se están empezando a
producir en la isla porque cuba si está
cambiando
cómo está cambiando cuba desde que raúl
castro llegó al poder el gobierno de
cuba ha reconocido que tiene que cambiar
el rumbo porque el modelo cubano
simplemente no funciona según dicen
quieren hacer lo que hizo china a
abrirse al mundo manteniendo el control
lo cierto es que hasta ahora los cambios
han sido muy lentos y muy escasos pero
aún así allá se están notando y ahora
que venezuela ya no puede ayudar a la
isla la urgencia de estos cambios es aún
mayor desde que en 2011 se introdujeron
reformas y se facilitaron los negocios
por cuenta propia el número de
trabajadores autónomos en cuba' se ha
multiplicado por cuatro y hoy ya supera
el medio millón el gobierno también ha
comenzado a permitir la producción
agrícola privada para los pequeños
campesinos e incluso los restaurantes y
pequeños negocios privados enfocados al
turismo están creciendo como la espuma
la apertura de obama ha ayudado
muchísimo en todo este proceso casi
todos los negocios privados en cubas se
montan con el dinero que llegan ahora
así de las remesas y por ejemplo el bien
vi tiene ya en cuba 22 mil apartamentos
casas o habitaciones entre sus ofertas y
además nunca podemos olvidar que el
intercambio de ideas el conocimiento de
lo que ocurre en el exterior y el
fortalecimiento del sector privado es la
mejor forma de lograr cambios políticos
cuando un estadounidense visita la isla
y ojo cada vez son más con cada
conversación y con cada dólar que gastan
en taxis particulares pequeños
restaurantes o habitaciones favorecen no
solo la mejora de vida de los cubanos
sino que también mejoran su capacidad
para ser libres fijaos sino en china y
comparada la china de hoy con la china
de mao desde que este país abría el
mundo cientos de millones de chinos han
dejado atrás la pobreza y encima con su
producción han permitido que otros
muchos millones de personas en el resto
del mundo también hayan mejorado su
nivel de vida china como cuba sigue
siendo hoy una horrible dictadura pero
gracias a la apertura a los chinos hoy
tienen más libertad al tiempo que han
mejorado su nivel de vida
[Música]
la política del embargo ha fracasado y
el empeño de trump por volver atrás no
va a lograr nada más que debilitar la
seguridad de eeuu empobrecer al pueblo
cubano y frenar los cambios en la isla
según parece en 2018 el propio raúl
castro dejará el poder y la verdad
amigos no es el momento de dar marcha
atrás además en 2013 el gobierno cubano
suprimió las visas de salida hoy no es
extraño que miembros de la sociedad
civil como empresarios académicos o
disidentes políticos salgan y regresen
al país y esto es un gran paso porque
facilita la cooperación con empresas
sociedades y organismos internacionales
trump se justifica según el dice en
querer defender los derechos humanos eso
está bien pero nos parece un tanto
hipócrita defender el embargo de cuba y
al mismo tiempo abrazarse con los
dirigentes de arabia saudita donde
quedan ahí los derechos humanos
[Música]
y ojo por todo esto 10 senadores
republicanos han criticado ya
fuertemente el cambio de rumbo respecto
a cuba los cubanos ya están viendo un
repunte en su nivel de vida a causa de
su comercio con nosotros creo que es un
error retroceder pero ahora te toca el
turno a ti puedes dejarnos tu opinión en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta debe donald trump dar marcha
atrás a la política de obama respecto a
cuba si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a
like y ya sabes si quieres seguir al
tanto de todas nuestras novedades no te
olvides de suscribirte al canal y de
seguirnos también en facebook y twitter
un saludo y hasta la próxima
no no no
obama
yo qué
la cartera con las botas
[Música]